this is video of George Herbert Walker
Bush when he crashed into the sea as a
young pilot it's what we call a hero if
you're young playing video games
shopping online or fulminating on
Facebook it's because of something
called leisure time and leisure time was
brought to you by millions of men and
women whose bravery in times of war made
our idle activity possible I wonder
would we even be here if it weren't for
men like him the passing of George
Herbert Walker Bush reminds me of the
recent passing of John McCain it also
reminds me that only losing great men
and women unifies people we try to
forget all about the other crap in fact
we realize much of that crap is
pointless
people come and go on our planet and in
our lives and it helps to remember that
all of us have something in common with
the great ones with the exception of a
few chuckle buckets who use such events
to score political points it's actually
a shared loss that reveals how we really
are none of us tweet in the face of
death kind l'heure and gentler remember
those words it's a return to the
baseline of human goodness a great
person dies and we can observe the
rituals with reverence and respect as
though it's second nature god help those
who can't it's probably best to ignore
them so for this week it's not a bad
thing to use this passing of a great man
as an excuse to make life better
let's finger-pointing more handshakes
I'm sure in time we'll get back to our
tribes but for now let's do the guy a
favor be kind and gentle in case he's
watching so Dana I'm sitting actually in
your chair which I feel quite strange
so do I yes I don't like being this
close to Jessi yep stop touching me
under the table so Dana you're what the
reverence lasted ten seconds yes Danny
you're in DC there are the state
funerals tomorrow what are your thoughts
anything that moved you particularly
today yes well it's obviously an honor
to be here and to be able to have known
them and to talk about them I thought
your monologue was spot on Greg spot you
bloody on very good a couple of things
that touched me today
I got a chance to interview Vice
President Dan Quayle yes and to look
back at 1988 when he gave the convention
speech then and of course you know I
mean I remember that time I'm sure you
guys do too maybe Jesse does it might be
too too young maybe Lisa booth wasn't
paying attention man because she's so
young as well but it does just you
realize that things change parties
evolve people have a way of sort of
forgetting what things were like back
then and so moments like this allow you
to a chance to pause the moment that
really touched me today though was when
Senator Bob Dole went to the Capitol
he's 95 years old and as you see there
he is
helped by an assistant to stand so that
he could properly and in his way pay his
respects to George HW Bush who was a
very good friend of his of course they
were competitors but friendly
competitors but Gregg I think it was
last week we were talking about the
greatest generation I'm sorry actually
it was Andy Ferguson's piece right he
was a friend of yours and a speechwriter
for George HW Bush and he wrote about a
speech he had to give in which in 1992
and during his re-election the political
consultants said don't talk about his
war service don't let him talk about his
war service because it will make him
look too old right in comparison to Bill
Clinton then four weeks before the
election the political consultants
changed their minds and think oh wait
maybe we should highlight his war
service and he writes this speech and at
the end of it he says in the article he
wrote Ferguson says nearly all of them
are gone now and I think maybe that's
why it feels very poignant yeah this
Greatest Generation
we're having to say goodbye to them it's
truly he's it's not just mr. Bush it's
who he symbolizes an entire I mean
millions of men that know are no longer
here one you worked for I mean were you
at you at the post within the 88 I mean
you probably ran into President Bush
when he wasn't president or vice
president he was vice pres when I spent
most of the time with and was flying
around the country going to Republican
events to try to help get Ronald Reagan
re-elected great and so I had a
wonderful time it was kind of like you
know being at the feet of them
asked her because he talked about a
political he had been head of the
Republican National Committee in
addition to running twice for Senate
unsuccessfully than holding a House seat
twice from Houston so he had been
through a lot politically knew all the
political leadership going back to the
Goldwater days of 64 and you talk about
a Republican Party expert and in terms
of I was I was just saying you know he's
famous for writing notes to people and
I'm sure Dana has a ton I have some but
he would write notes to all these party
leaders so that they felt that they had
a personal relationship with him and the
the the axiom here was don't call
somebody up to ask a favor a political
favor a personal favor right out the box
without saying how you're doing who are
you how are the kids and that's the
relationship he had so that even people
who disagreed with him specifically I
would guess in you know in this day of
tribes as you say Greg the Democrats oh
my gosh Democrats had a pretty good
relationship I mean not didn't always
come to good political ends because
remember in terms of the budget deal
where he allowed taxes to be raised in
order to lower the deficit it was then
held against him by some in the party
especially the far-right the Newt
Gingrich types who said oh you know
you're breaking your pledge not to raise
taxes read my lips no new taxes but this
is a you know an example I keep saying
that I would hold up to my children as
the kind of person that you want to be
someone who is about public service love
of country love of family just the and
treated people as individuals not as g
i'm george w HW bush and who were you
know it was like tell me about you jesse
thoughts i'm just some personal
reflections because I kind of came up
under the age of Bush you know he was
the vice presidency when I was young and
then his presidency and then his son's
presidency kind of kind of formed who I
thought a great statesman in America
would be just a few things come to mind
humility dignity class and love you
think about he oversaw America winning
the Cold War that was a time where he
could have said Americans should just
beat our chests and gloat
spike the football instead he didn't and
he said absolutely nothing and that
silence was very important at that time
and that was a very powerful moment I
think he was you know raised in the prep
school boarding school era where you
know good sportsmanship is drilled into
you and he always won with class and
dignity also when he kicked Saddam out
of Kuwait he had an opportunity to rush
to Baghdad and overthrow the entire
government and he was humble enough to
know the limitations of American
military power and I think everyone
Republicans and Democrats look back at
that and say that was a very wise and
humble and noble decision Juan picked up
on a few things the personal
relationships he had with people
professional relationships friendships
he really conducted it in a classy way
he communicated on stationery or picking
up the phone and he did that for so many
decades that he generated so much
goodwill and towards the end the
Republican Party was the party of push
the rolodex all of the people that he
knew that networks across the entire
country just had so much honor and
reverence for him and his family that
when he called and asked for something
was sure it wasn't a political favor it
was you were doing something for a
friend and then lastly love in terms of
his relationship with Barbara and his
sons publicly at least you'd think a man
if his generation wouldn't be
conditioned to show that kind of
affection towards other people
especially his family in public but his
love and affection the way he displayed
it was very modern he wasn't afraid of
embracing people and crying and and
articulating that love and I think every
father and every son in this country
should look at the relationship that he
had with his sons and say that is how a
true father-son relationship should be
well what's gonna say I found myself
this week reading his letters and I
think there's been so much talk about
his integrity kindness the kind of man
he he was and if you read his letters
you can see it and you know the written
word always lasts so much longer than
you know what
say auntie D or what you say during a
debate or what have you and that's a
beautiful thing for him because what a
great legacy to leave behind and you
know vice president Mike Pence talked
about this yet yesterday when the former
president when he wrote a letter to his
son when he landed his first tailhook
landing as a Marine aviator and saying
that he shares the pride that Mike Pence
has in his son you look at the letter he
left Bill Clinton saying that you're our
president I am rooting for you even
though he defeated him and he was a
one-term president what a beautiful
thing to have that sort of character to
leave that message for Bill Clinton you
look at the love letters to Barbara on
what a beautiful loving relationship
that they had as a couple the letter
that he wrote about his daughter Robin
who they lost and talking about the fact
that she's always going to remain with
them so just all these letters what a
beautiful legacy for him to leave behind
for future Americans to see the kind of
integrity that the man had so Dana
what's gonna happen tomorrow at the
funeral well you'll have eulogies from
George W Bush I think that one will be
hard for me to get through because you
know quite close to him and as
Christopher Buckley another speechwriter
wrote that they might have been New
England roots but they had the tear
ducts of a Sicilian grandmother then you
have Brian Mulroney who is a prime
minister of Canada one of forty-ones
best friends on the world stage former
senator Alan Simpson from the great
state of Wyoming will also eulogize him
and then will be finalized with Jon
Meacham of the the historian who wrote
so much about him the last thing I would
say is something that Greg I think with
you and I've said this several times 41
really embodied this and then we should
all keep this in mind politics might be
what we do but it is not who we are
yeah buddy all right thanks Dana